you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
65 people have died in algeria as
soaring temperatures mean wildfires
continue across north africa europe and
california
more extreme heat heading for spain and
portugal with record temperatures in
tunisia and a new heatwave for the
northwest of the united states and
canada
and why our fast-changing climate is
putting ten thousand cherished
archaeological and heritage sites at
risk
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
more than 60 people have died in algeria
in wildfires fanned by extreme
temperatures across the region
fires are being fought in greece italy
and the united states all while more
severe heat is expected across southern
europe including temperatures of more
than 45 degrees celsius in spain and
portugal
it's the latest evidence of extreme
conditions that scientists say are
exacerbated by the effects of climate
change
so let's start in algeria where the
number of those killed by wildfires has
started to rise sharply today as extreme
heat sweeps north africa
so these are the latest pictures from
the country where 65 people are now
known to have died in fires twenty-five
soldiers were killed fighting the fires
in forested parts in the north of the
country including in the worst hit area
tizi uzu
and here you can see the impact of those
fires in algeria now this is from the
eu's copernicus program which shows
particulate matter from the fires in
algeria but also in southern italy and
greece as well this is from midday today
meanwhile this from nasa shows plumes of
smoke from the fires again from algeria
and other fires across southern europe
and the mediterranean and you can see
the fires indicated by orange dots and
the smoke drifting away from them
in california the vast dixie fire now
the second largest in the state's
history is just 21 contained having
consumed some half a million acres of
land
tinder dry forests and high temperatures
have sustained this fire since mid-july
sky's mark stone spoke to one of those
working to contain it people saying that
the forests are not being managed in the
way perhaps they used to be the native
americans used to manage them and that
is helping combined with climate change
that is helping to create this disaster
well the drought conditions have
definitely been a challenge to manage
through the pace and scale of
reforestation activities fuel
breaks and fuel and vegetation
treatments has increased across the
forest service here on the plumas
specifically on the dixie fire all of
the land management agencies are
struggling because of the climate change
and the the longer burning season and
the longer fire seasons
well fires have been burning in greece
for nine days now prompting the prime
minister to apologize for a lack of
preparedness
foreign firefighters have now started
work and migrating stalks are being
badly affected by the smoke well sky's
sally lockwood is in arcadia in greece
so sally the government there has
acknowledged that more action uh could
have been taken ahead of these fires how
much is being done to adapt and to
mitigate yeah certainly uh the greek
prime minister addressing the nation
this week did grasp the nettle uh and
talked about at the issue of climate
change which of course is affecting so
much
of the country in terms of these
wildfires which have been burning for
more than a week now he challenged
anyone who didn't believe in climate
change to come and have a look at what's
happening in greece and acknowledge that
the steps taken so far simply do not go
far enough so what is greece doing here
well to put it into context uh greece is
the 11th highest
emitter of carbon uh in the eu germany
the highest uh and it did of course sign
up to the paris uh climate change
agreement it's pledged to reduce its
carbon emissions by more than half by
2030 and to reach
net zero by 2050 but as we know uh many
of those promises made in paris simply
do don't go far enough but one thing uh
that's quite interesting that greece
has done
in july of this year they appointed a
chief heat officer for athens the first
in europe only the second in the world
after miami-dade
county in america
and this heat officer really their job
is to look at the city look at how heat
and extreme weather impacts how people
live and to try and mitigate against uh
the impact rainfall in the summer in
greece is down by around 20 to 30
percent what we need is the
international community of course to
come together and to find long-term
solutions for climate change but one
glimmer of hope for this community in
the next 24 hours there is that there is
some long-awaited rain with a storm due
tomorrow
sally thank you well if those
devastating wildfires are the
consequence one cause is extreme heat it
means fires are more extensive and
severe and harder to counter and we know
from the stark warnings in the ipcc
report that more extreme heat is already
happening because of climate change
now spain and portugal are bracing for
temperatures above 45 degrees celsius
and records could be broken across
southern europe the portuguese prime
minister has warned that's likely to
mean wildfires in his country too
well north africa and southern europe
are facing temperatures much higher than
expected at this time of year the
tunisian capital tunis hit a new record
temperature of 48.9 degrees breaking the
previous high of 47.4 degrees celsius
from 1943.
now you'd normally expect low to mid 30s
at this time of year but it hit 47
degrees in lentini in sicily
and that matches italy's all-time
temperature record europe's all-time
record is 48 degrees in athens in 1977.
even that could be challenged as the
heat will gradually move west through
the mediterranean over the next few days
peaking in spain and portugal over the
weekend where temperatures of 47 degrees
are expected and spain's current
all-time record is 47.3 degrees from
just four years ago
and you may remember the heat dome that
brought extreme temperatures to the
pacific northwest of the united states
and parts of canada or similar
conditions unlikely to return over the
next few days now we might not get the
same highs but temperatures will be well
above august averages possibly by as
much as 10 degrees celsius
so how extreme are those temperatures
and just how much are they being driven
by climate change well i can ask that to
professor peter stott who's a science
fellow in climate attribution at the met
office so welcome to you so can we say
at this stage that these very high
temperatures are the result of climate
change
well we can say that climate change is
playing an important role in these very
high temperatures
it's the weather that brings the
particular meteorological conditions but
it's climate change that's effectively
adding fuel to the fire of that weather
and we looked actually at the canadian
uh extreme temperatures that we saw back
in june when canadian temperatures
reached as high as 49.6 degrees celsius
which is a a massive 4.6 degrees celsius
warmer than the previous record
and found that climate change had made
the chances of having such extreme
temperatures very very much more likely
about 4 000 times more likely be
calculated
so it's very clear that climate change
is making these extreme conditions even
more extreme and giving us these
extraordinary record-breaking
temperatures
well yes you use the word extraordinary
i was going to use that word for the
series of events that we've seen from
heat waves to floods over the last few
weeks and months what have you made of
it i've made of it that
what we climate scientists have been
predicting for
several decades now
is really with us
we've we've very accurately predicted
the rise in global average temperature
which are now about 1.1 degrees celsius
warmer than pre-industrial levels
and from for many years now climate
scientists have been predicting that
this would bring in it is train
extreme weather more heat waves more
floods and much more damaging heat waves
and floods and and storms
and
what we're now seeing and and we're not
seeing it just this summer but we've
seen it in recent summers in the
northern hemisphere we're seeing a
succession of these very damaging
extremes and it's very very clear that
climate change is now with us and that
is exactly what the recent ipcc report
has concluded
in today's other climate news heavy
rainfall has triggered floods and
landslides on the northern coast of
turkey as the south of the country
continues to battle wildfires the
extreme weather tore down a bridge
injuring at least 13 people and has left
12 villages without power the disaster
and emergency management presidency has
warned that strong rains in the area
will continue
ocean's campaigner louis pugh will
attempt the coldest swim on earth to
highlight the effects of climate change
his swim will stretch across the 10
kilometer mouth of the illicit ice fjord
which is fed by the world's fastest
moving glacier
scientists predict global sea levels
will rise by seven meters if greenland's
ice sheets melt entirely
the red arrows could go green as part of
efforts to reach net zero by 2040. the
red arrows smoke trails currently are
comprised of 75 diesel and 25 die and
the planes used over 600 thousand liters
of diesel in 2018. defence equipment and
support a trading arm of the ministry of
defense is searching for environmentally
friendly smoke dye and fuel alternatives
and royal marine commandos attempting a
record row to raise awareness of ocean
plastic have arrived at tower bridge in
london the north atlantic road started
in brooklyn bridge and after 64 days the
rowers reached british waters
now the wildfires spurred on by those
extreme temperatures in greece
threatened some of the most famous sites
in all of human history olympia and
marathon
but closer to home we know that climate
change is also putting some of the uk's
most cherished archaeological sites in
danger
experts have told the daily climate show
that more than 10 000 heritage sites
here could disappear
while air pollution can erode the
limestone and sandstone blocks that make
up many ancient structures like the
pyramids of giza in egypt and the rose
granite used in lots of egyptian
artifacts is starting to crack as
fluctuating temperatures cause the rock
to expand and then to contract
and these temperature changes are
damaging cave paintings in indonesia too
as temperatures rise and fall salt
crystals in the cave walls expand and
contract causing the paint to flake and
the iconic maui statues placed along the
edges of rapa nui otherwise known as
easter island are critically at risk and
that's because of coastal erosion
future digs are also in danger
scientists estimate there are at least
180 000 archaeological sites in the
arctic and very few of them have been
excavated but melting ice sheets and
tundra fire means many of these sites
will be lost
well let's focus then on the impact in
the uk now and speak to dr allison
sheridan formerly principal curator of
early prehistory at national museum
scotland and archaeologist of the year
2020 so welcome to you
so tell us what could the impact be on
our archaeological sites and historic
areas of interest in the uk
the greatest threat is from coastal
erosion
where
increasing storminess is going to scour
the coastline we can see it already and
you also have the problem of rising sea
level at the same time so we find that
there are iconic sites such as scarabray
which are now threatened because the sea
is much much closer than it ever was uh
when the site was was first constructed
about five thousand years ago
so what can be done about it
all over britain the archaeological
authorities the government authorities
are monitoring
sites and monitoring erosion so in
scotland there is an escape trust which
is the scottish coastal archaeology and
the problem of erosion trust which has
set out to survey scotland's coastline
there's about 19 000 kilometers of
coastline to to survey and so they've
only been able to do a small amount of
it but they've they've identified
there's something like 12 000 sites on
the coast and of those a thousand are
threatened and 145 are critically
threatened just now
um the scottish government is is funding
uh part funding a phd by dr by eleanor
graham of the university of aberdeen
who is doing drone surveys to assess the
amount of coasts that has gone has been
scoured and who can then predict how
much more of the coast is going to go
and you can
repeat this exercise around britain so
um we've seen on the east coast for
example uh you get a lot of slumping of
the and you get
whole cliffs that are crumbling away on
the south coast of england
dr alison sheridan thanks very much
indeed well that's everything from us
for today next time how much carbon
dioxide is being generated by wildfires
you can find out more here on the daily
climate show tomorrow see you then
[Music]
you